Hey everyone, I'm just going to take you over the first module of
the Marquee Structured Training for the Indicator.
Now the first module is Swing Structure.
Now, honestly, when it comes to the education behind this,
you know, I don't need to go too in-depth on what Swing Structure is.
You've all come from YouTube videos, you know, you have a very clear understanding
of what Swing Structure is, and we've built this into an Indicator.
So, the Indicator is going to do the work for you.
But what I'm going to do is I'm just going to quickly explain it,
just so you have a clear understanding. And then I'll take you over to
the Indicator, and I'll explain the Swing Structure while on the Indicator,
because the Indicator is what you're going to be using. Now,
it's pretty simple. You know, I'm sure you're all aware of this,
right? We, Swing Structure is the swing points of your
video. You know, it's the points that are either strong or weak.
You know, we want to follow these points. Very simple.
We have a low. We have a high.
Then we have a high-low. Why is that a high-low? Because it's higher than
the previous low, okay? This is a very basic feature here.
Then we have a high-up. Why? Because it's higher than the previous high.
Then we have a high-low, high-high, high-low,
high-high, low-low. Why is this a low-low?
Because it's lower than the previous low. This here is what we would call
a change of character. Okay,
so if you was to mark that up, on there, it would be a
change of character. Very simple.
Alright? So.
And then, once we had a change of character, the downside here,
you can see that price then had a price of a pullback into this
range, right? At this point, after this change of character,
we only have two swing points that we'd be paying attention to.
So, we'd have a swing high, and we'd have a swing low.
But this swing low, we only know is a swing low once we've had
a valid pullback. And that's what the indicator does for you.
It gives you a pullback rule. The reason most people mess up structure,
and why so many others don't have a clear
understanding of how to restructure, is because they don't know they don't have a
rule to tell them what a pullback is.
So if you don't have a rule for pullback, you aren't going to know
if it's a valid highs or a valid lows. And every time it's going
to be completely random. So what we've done is we've put that rule into
the indicator. The indicator will know if it's a pullback because of the rule.
So we have a low, and then we have price pullback into this range
and then continue to the downside, okay? Once
price then breaks this low, this then becomes our valid swing high.
Now, remember, until price breaks this low,
because this is the swing low, you know,
we've had a pullback, this becomes a swing low. Until price breaks this low,
we don't have a confirmed high. So this wouldn't just become a swing high
just because it pulls back, because you could have a situation where price would
pull back, and then continue. And then this is where people
start to mess up, this is where people get structure wrong.
They class this as a high, this then becomes a higher low because it's
higher than this low, this becomes a higher high, then they start looking for
buys, and before you know it,
price is going to come straight through. Why?
Because this is what we call internal structure, which is what I'm going to
walk you through in the next module. It's quite simple.
So this swing high is only confirmed when this low goes.
So when price trades up and it trades down,
I'm taking this low, causing a break in structure.
We look at the highest point before this break.
That's how you can always use it, right? Always look for the highest point
before the break. And that would be this high here.
And then again, you can see price then reverses from here.
At this point, it's this high.
And this low, right?
This high is meant to be strong. You know, we've had a change of
character to the downside, we've been at bear strength. This high is the one
we want to stay strong. But, you know,
that isn't always the case, right? What you can see happens is we have
a change of character to the upside.
So price reverses. Purchase shifts from bearish to bullish.
Okay. And then after this change of character,
we had a pullback confirming the high.
And then we had a shift in here when we but this does
not get confirmed yet until this high goes, the high has to go.
Once this high is then taken again, this is now confirmed our new
higher low.
So it's that simple.
Okay. Quick walkthrough of that. We have a low,
we have a high, we have a higher low, higher high,
higher low, higher high, Change of character,
lower low. And we have a lower high,
because it's lower than the previous high, and a lower low.
Very simple. That's how it works, right? I don't want to bore you too
much. I don't want to bore you for that. It's very basic. If you
have any questions, just let me know in the community.
If not, cool. We'll just move into the indicator,
because this is the important part, right? We need to be able to follow
the indicator. Now, imagine the indicator wasn't here,
right? Imagine the indicator wasn't here.
This would look very messy. And some people would,
if I gave this chart to 100 people,
without a pullback rule, so many of yous would mark
this up completely different. You'd all have different highs and lows.
Okay? So, when we turn this on,
it's very basic. You know, it's not difficult to understand.
Swing structure is going to be the external points.
Okay? Now, it will be marked out also.
You can see HH, which is higher high.
HL, which is higher low. Okay?
Then, if we take this high,
you see here we whipped it, right? This wasn't break structure.
Because, we, we only whipped it,
we didn't close. We have to close with a candle.
That's an important thing with the rule that we have, right?
That's how, that's why this stays the low,
this doesn't. Okay? Some people would get that wrong.
Now, we have our high. We have a higher high.
We have And then we actually have a breaker structure to the upside.
Where's the lowest point that caused that breaker structure?
It's here. So this was our swing point.
Okay? This is our swing bar.
Now, if I was to take this back,
This
would be our internal low-low. Why is that?
Does anyone have- Does anyone understand that? Because right now,
This is still internal structure. Remember what I said earlier,
this is where you can't get too confused. Until this high goes,
we will not know the swing point yet.
So this stays internal. This is how we then use internal,
right? You can see anything that's marked up internal, it will be I in
front of it. Now, we know that the swing structure here is
bullish, right? We know that this is the swing low,
because this was the lowest point before the break structure to the outside,
and then this was the highest point before a valid pullback,
okay? Valid pullback onto there. So the range of the swing this low to
this high. We know we're bullish, so we're expecting high prices.
How can we use the internal here? Well,
we can see we had an internal change of character. Now that internal change
of character after this pullback, you know, we've pulled back,
That internal change of character shows me that we're likely to realign
internal with swing.
So then you can start to look to take the swing high.
Okay, and you could play that out.
I don't want to take too much time.
How can I skip this first?
Yeah. And you can see,
just like that, right? We knew this was an internal change of character.
Also, as you've just seen, right?
When we really look and move, when we,
uh, actually break a high, the internal structure disappears.
And so you will only see internal structure as it's playing out.
You know, once the swing points have changed,
swing structure changed, we could have used that,
you know, if we was to go into an area,
find an area of. Demand, find an oil block or a fair value gap,
we could have used this internal change of character as our shift to then
target a high and then trade to the upside. Okay.
But now what happened? When I said earlier,
this is the swing low, right? What happened was.
When price actually broke this high with a candle close,
this then became a swing low. Because this was the lowest point,
this area here was the lowest point before we had the breaker structure.
So that becomes our swing point. Okay?
So that's how it works. It's pretty simple. Then you can play it out
again. We'll do swing structure together.
Let me delete that. Play it out,
swing structure. We have a new swing high.
Why? Because we've had a valid pullback.
Based on the rule that we have, we know that we've had a pullback,
so this can become a swing high. This becomes a swing
low, because we then broke that high to the upside.
So now you have this as a swing low. So now everything that happened
here, forget about it. This is now your swing low.
We're bullish at this point, okay? So your swing low is here.
We haven't got a swing high yet, that's why it's dashed, because we haven't
had a valid pullback. Now we've had a valid pullback.
So now the range that we're trading within is this high and this low.
Okay? You can do the box method that's like we've taught on YouTube,
go from the low to the high. Anything within this box now
is internal. As you can see,
we have an internal low, then we have an internal break structure. We have
an internal high put in place, we have a chock,
we're going to have a liquidity sweep, then we have a change of character
to the downside, and then we have a change of character on the 15
minute. So now what's just happened? We've just gone from bullish to bullish.
Swing structure on the 15 minute to bearish,
we've had a change of character. Where's the swing high?
Let me take this back just so you don't get too confused.
There's a valid pullback in here, which is why that changed.
But at this point here, okay,
we had this. The high, right,
the highest point, and then we had this low.
This low gets taken, that's our change of character. That's us going from bullish
to bearish. Now, we are able to pull all the way back up into
here, before we continue low. But what actually happens is.
It's because of the rule that we have for a pullback,
if we play it out, you can see the
range changes very quickly. Because it goes from a break structure,
pullback, a change of character, pullback,
to a break structure. So now this is our swing high.
We haven't yet to confirm a low yet, which is why it dashed,
because we haven't had a pullback yet. So we continue.
Boom. We've had a valid pullback. Then the swing low shifts.
Same again. Okay? It's this markout structure as we go.
Now, how to change a character here to the upside. So we've gone from
Bearish, Swing,
to Bullish. How to change a character.
We've had a valid pullback. This becomes our swing high.
This is our swing low. Okay?
Now, bear in mind, I'm right now just sitting on a 15-minute time frame.
You know, when we're using more time frames, you've got your 4-hour,
you've got your 15-minute, you've got your daily, you've got your 1-minute,
which is the 1-minute is where we always enter. You could then use these
together, which is something I'm going to show you in another module.
And how you would do that, right? So,
let's just play this out. Break structure to the outside,
15-minute structure. Remember, you will always see it,
because it's always going to play itself out.
Don't know how to change a character. Now, what
are we expecting to happen? Something that's important here is what you've got to
remember is, like I said,
about the different time zones, about the different time frames.
We know that we've just shifted. We know bearish during London,
right, London session shifted bearish. That means the 50 minute is now bearish.
What you want to do then is we know we want to look for
shorts. So when we're in the one, when we're in New York and we're
on a lower time frame, like the one minute, for instance.
You then look for a shift on the one minute